anthony même bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france alors on vient de
l'évoquer un télégramme a porté plainte
contre apple l'accusant de pratiques
anticoncurrentielles concrètement qu'est
ce que cela signifie sur les plans
juridique et économique
en effet le droit européen et le droit
français réglemente l'abus de position
dominante à partir du moment où une
entreprise dispose d'une avance
technologique comme apple ou d'une
situation de monopole comme apple
elle peut être facilement considérés en
tant que tels
responsable d'un abus de position
dominante et avoir à payer 10% de
sanction de son chiffre d'affaires
mondial hors taxes pour indemniser
justement ce monopole empêchant ses
concurrents de pouvoir participer au
développement des applications dans le
cas d'appels l'abus de position
dominante se manifestent simplement en
effet pour pouvoir être sur apple
disposer d'une application apple prélève
30 % 30 % sur tous les développeurs sur
toutes les applications et on comprend
que du fait de son avance technologique
et du fait de son monopole
apple abuse et ce faisant il y a eu de
la part de télégrammes messenger une
plainte qui a été déposée il ya quelques
jours auprès de la commission européenne
afin de sanctionner apple pour que apple
c'est ce qu'on a vu en prélevant autant
30 % pour chaque développeur dansons
pour faire partie de son programme de
son apple store et alors est ce que
c'est est-ce que la messagerie
instantanée pour obtenir gain de cause
devant la commission européenne comment
et les g pourrait argumenter pour
démontrer concrètement à des pratiques
anticoncurrentielles télégramme
messenger pourrait simplement dire que
compte tenu de sa situation apple est en
situation de monopole elle abuse parce
que 30% de commission c'était un homme
et comme il n'y a pas d'autre concurrent
évidemment apple risque d'être
sanctionné lourdement et
je pense que à terme ce qui va se passer
c'est qu'avec le temps et les plaintes
qui vont être déposées
apple devra diminuer ces commissions
pour permettre justement à ce que les
applications puissent être sur l'apple
store parce que le problème c'est que
ceux qui développent des applications et
qu'ils doivent payer 30% ne pourront pas
forcément développer de nouvelles
applications parce que justement apple
prendra toute leur marge et on comprend
que c'est le serpent qui se mord la
queue
à terme c'est les technologies qui
risquent de temps pâtir et les
développements les développeurs
d'applications qui risque de ne plus
développer d'application
la ligne de défense pour apple en
concernant les tarifs de son l'app store
n'a pas changé ces dernières années
selon la firme elles toutes ces règles
sont notamment justifiée par des
impératifs de sécurité
est-ce que cet argument pour être
démontée est cette fois-ci par la
commission européenne
alors il ya plusieurs arguments en effet
qui sont développés à chaque fois par
apple parce que ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'apple est sujet d'une plainte
devant la commission européenne il ya eu
n'explique spotify qui ont eu aussi des
déposé des plaintes auprès de la
commission pour la même chose cet abus
rabut abus de position dominante est en
réalité apple se cachent toujours
derrière les prétendus failles de
sécurité des applications pour refuser
une application dans son apple store est
en réalité il n'ya aucune faille de
sécurité
c'est un alibi un argument qui est jeté
en pâture comme ça par apple et qui est
sans aucun fondement
en pratique alors justement où elles en
sont ces les enquêtes concernant spotify
et rapid and rakuten
en effet c'est plein de sons récente
elle date de la fin de l'année dernière
du mois de juin dernier aussi donc on
comprend que ce sont des procédures qui
soit quand même lourde et avec de
lourdes conséquences
et donc il est fort à parier que dans
les mois à venir une décision sera prise
par la commission européenne qui visera
certainement à sanctionner apple merci
beaucoup anthony même d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste du numérique